the Palestinian President Mahmoud Abbas
has made an impassioned plea for stated
at the United Nations General Assembly
despite us pressure to stop the bed
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu responded by saying his
country sought lasting peace 10 Middle
East but insisted that Palestinians
sovereignty had to be pursued through
direct negotiations the truth is that I
want these the truth is that in the
Middle East at all times but especially
during these turbulent days peace must
be anchored in security the truth is
that we cannot achieve peace through UN
resolutions but only through direct
negotiations between the parties the
truth is it so far the Palestinians have
refused to negotiate the truth is that
Israel wants peace with a Palestinian
state but the Palestinians want want a
state without peace and the truth is you
shouldn't let that happen Nathan yahoo
was responding to the Palestinian bid
for a sovereign state in his speech to
the General Assembly President Abbas
urged Israel to build bridges of
dialogue and sort of walls of separation
he was greeted with a standing ovation
here in one I do not believe that anyone
with a shred of conscience our
application for a full membership in the
United Nations and our admission as an
independent state
president I come here today carrying a
message from a courageous and proud
people Palestine is being reborn this is
the my message may all the people of the
world stand with the people of Palestine
as it marches steadfastly to its
appointment with history with freedom
with independence right now and I hope
that we shall not wait for long thank
you